the phone number is 6 1 7 8 30 40 750 we
will go to our next caller from the 479
area code caller what's your name and
where you're calling from this is David
calling from Arkansas great what's on
your mind my question my question is do
you believe that there is any viable
method of converting Trump supporters to
the truth apart from simply reporting on
the truth right well listen i don't
think reporting i don't you say apart
from reporting on the truth i don't know
that reporting on the truth is going to
convert trump supporters I've talked
about my the two views on this quite a
bit the two views are number one if you
appeal to trump supporters in the right
way so if you make moral arguments
rather than what we might consider sort
of rational arguments of sorts you might
get Trump supporters so for example if
you make issues of health care moral
issues where what Republicans want to do
on health care is immoral there's some
writing that says that's a better way to
appeal to trump voters the other view is
it's a lost cause we did a story earlier
this week about a woman who had a son
whose health insurance dropped
drastically in costs because of
Obamacare and she believes that Trump
care which hasn't passed is to thank for
the drop right how are you going to be
able to convince someone like that and
more importantly how much time would it
take you versus how long would it take
you to increase the progressive turn out
by five or ten votes and the idea that
forget about these people who you're not
going to be able to convince just work
on turning out the boat I i think that
there's arguments to be made on both
sides I mean what do you think that
there's any sort of effective way to
convert committed trumpets at the moment
no but I'm just considering whether it
would be you know good for America to
commute to the room from yeah that would
be great that would be great for America
I just don't know exactly how you do it
it seems many of them are pat
ideological
committed I don't think the spoken word
is going to work anymore at this point I
mean we've been through everything I
think it would have to be policy change
on the ground and that's really
unfortunate because in the case of
health care for example that may be
people losing their Medicaid coverage
the number of people who would lose
health insurance under the proposed
Republican healthcare plan is
exponentially larger than Trump's margin
of victory in Pennsylvania and so that
that's a big deal right that that could
absolutely swim the election all right
there's a few thoughts really appreciate
the call thank you okay you think we
lost that you're welcome